ви всі знаєте що ми переживаємо вже рік
і вісім місяців повномасштабну війну
війну з сильнішою країною з агресором з
країною яка повністю намагається нищити
нашу державність всі наші міста вбиває
українців але ситуація є досі такою що
на превеликий жаль представники
заборонених проросійських партій з
абсолютно проросійською позицією які а
свого часу не визнавали анексію Криму
які говорили що на Донбасі у нас воюють
українці з українцями які сували все
російське які наразі намагаються
боротися проти того щоби був була
заборонена церква Московського
патріархату ці представники досі
перебувають в місцевих радах і є
депутатами місцевих рад і у Верховній
Раді України також Минулого року РНБО
прийняло рішення де заборонила перелік
конкретних партій визнала їх
антиукраїнську діяльність визнала те що
їхня діяльність загрожує державному
суверенітету і зокрема Серед таких
партій були названі опозиційна платформа
за життя партія шаря і іншій ряд партій
на сьогоднішній день на превеликий жаль
ці партії не тільки представлені а
їхніми представниками в місцевих радах
абсолютно спокійно представники які були
обрані від опзж і заборонених партій
вони можуть очолювати комісії в місцеви
в місцевих радах у нас зокрема в
Київській мі міській раді а представнико
представник опзж очолює вдумайтеся
правоохоронну комісію Так коли
повномасштабна війна триває саме тому ми
європейська Солідарність ініціювали
декілька проектів рішень в Київській
міській раді зокрема серед них такі
проекти як заборона представникам
заборонених партій е очолювати керівні
посади займати керівні посади очолювати
комісії і постійні і входити до складу
тимчасових комісії Київської міської
ради ми також хочемо звернутися до
Верховної Ради щоб Верховна Рада
ухвалила всі необхідні законодавчі зміни
які уможливлять в подальшому Участь
представників
опзж в
представництві інтересів громадян
України бо незрозуміла які інтереси Вони
досі представляють і на чию користь
працюють і останнє рішення - це
призупинення здійснення такими
депутатами повноважень А як депутатів на
період воєнного часу якщо РНБО визнало ї
їхню антиукраїнську діяльність я якщо це
підтвердив верховний суд А це було
рішення вересня Минулого року то
незрозуміло що досі роблять представники
забороненої опзж в Київській міській
раді в Верховній Раді України і у всіх
місцевих радах і ми вітаємо Київську
обласну Раду яка вже спромоглася Прийма
прийняти відповідне рішення і наші
представники європейської солідарності
зокрема це просунули і депутати від пзж
в Київській обласній раді будуть
відсторонені від всіх подібних питань і
доступ до багатьох сенситивних питань в
тому числі які стосуються військових і
ми дуже сподіваємося що Київська міська
Рада також знайде в собі сили
спроможність проголосувати ініційовані
нами
рішення так всі ми живемо зовсім в іншій
країні коли війна розділила її на до і
після і зараз ми не маємо місця для
компромісів і тому вимагаємо щоб би
партії які показали себе як проросійські
як
колабораціоністи вони пішли геть з
української
політичної сфери і щоби вони не впливали
на життя нашого українського суспільства
і тому
зареєстроване фракцією європейської
Солідарність в київраді проекти рішення
які вимагають позбавити всіх прав
голосування очолювання комісій в
київраді і прийняття рішень і участі в
закритих До речі і засіданнях рад
і де
є таємна інформація і вони не мають
права доступу до цієї таємної інформації
ми вимагаємо щоби завтра на
засіданні сесії Київської міської ради
були негайно розглянуті і проголосовані
ці проекти рішення і щоби Київська рада
показала що ми маємо політичну волю
очистити свої ріди від колабораціоністів
і проросійських партій
А друзі я можу тільки вітати ну таку
активність нашої команди в Київській
міській раді і безумовно Ми будемо дуже
уважно слідкувати за завтрашнім
засіданням київсь міської ради тому що
це дійсно є виклик який стосується
національної безпеки України і хочу
нагадати що сама на жаль Верховна Рада в
цих питаннях пасе задніх і закриває очі
на ну таку присутність п'ятої колони
Кремля яка себе дуже там вільно почуває
давайте згадаємо минулий пленарний
тиждень емоційне голосування в першому
читанні за дуже м'який насправді
Урядовий закон про заборону Московської
церкви в Україні хто виступив проти
єдина команда - це колишні опзж тепер
вони називаються ПМЖ там але ну знаєте
можна назватися як завгодно сутність їх
не змінюється це п'ята колона Кремля І
от Наша команда в Верховній Раді України
зареєструвала низку постанов і проектів
законів щодо того як юридично Оце кубло
розплутати і розв'язати питання що Після
рішення Ради нацбезпеки і оборони Після
рішення Верховного Суду опзж дуже себе
ком комфортно почуває в парламенті
знаємо що там два роки знадобилося щоби
Шуфрича зняти з посади голови комітету з
питань свободи слова до останнього його
партнери по голосуванню слуги народу
захищали ну і зараз у нас представники
опзж Вони залишаються на посадах там
заступників секретарів комітетів І
власне мають право створювати нові групи
їздять у відрядження міжнародні закриті
в тому числі ну знаєте там до наших
партнерів де обговорюється питання
збройної ді дсно підтримки Мають доступ
до державної таємниці Це ненормально от
в Верховній Раді України зареєстрована
постанова про відкликання з керівних
посад представників опзж
8348 Голова Верховної Ради і слуги її не
помічають постанова
7694 да про припинення дострокове
повноважень депутатів заборонених партій
не тільки в Верховній Раді Ну а і ми
говоримо і Про місцеві ради так само її
ніхто не помічає в порядок дено її не
виносять законопроект
8089 Про встановлення юридичних
наслідків для статусу народних депутатів
і депутатів місцевих РД із врахуванням
рішення суду щодо заборони політичних
партії зновутаки цей законопроект не
виноситься в порядок денний
АА чому коли у нас всі кричать да Влада
що ми будемо боротися з п'ятою колоною
Кремля чому така дивна позиція Ну вона
очевидна тому ще давно немає в Верховній
Раді України ніякої монобільшості якщо
ви подивитесь всі голосування немає 226
за жоден законопроект навіть коли він
приходить від президента Зеленського і
для цього потрібні їм донори донорами
виступають якщо мова йде про якусь
гадость лубійську або корупцію
обов'язково там буде опзж от Подивіться
всі голосування такі І наступного тижня
до речі виносять до сесійної зали вже в
другому повторному читанні законопроект
наприклад 137 які стосуються по суті
наступу на місцеве
самоврядування на те щоби забрати в
місцевого
самоврядування на під кінець уже
бюджетного року 200 млрд грн Я до речі
хочу подякувати нашій команді в київраді
яка за її по суті ініціативою виділила
на останній сесії Київради 1 млрд грн на
допомогу і підтримку підрозділів де
служать Кияни де воюють Кияни в гаряч
зараз куточках лінії фронту на те щоби
забезпечити ці підрозділи і дронами і
технікою і іншим і саме так мають
витрачатися ці кошти але уже зараз Влада
шукає голоси для того щоб оцей
законопроект 137 підтримати і
обов'язково там побачите буде опзж тому
що їх тримають на гачку дуже міцна і це
дуже зручно тут ми говоримо що Так ви ж
опзж там кримінальні папочки проти вас
але будете себе добре поводити
голосувати за все потрібне ось ці
законопроекти європейської солідарності
яка я перерахувала не вийдуть в порядок
денний Я хочу сказати що це дуже
шкідлива позиція і закінчиться все тим
як із шуфричем як із законом про
е церкву коли блокувалися саме слугами
саме керівництвом парламенту винесення в
порядок денний цих законопроектів і по
опзж дадуть відповідь от чим ближче до
виборів чим більше буде запитань до
влади така що відбувається у вас яка оця
Спайка ваша з опзж вони винесуть ці
законопроекти можливо під своїми
прізвищами в порядок денний але це треба
робити зараз ну і користуючись Насправді
нагодою Я хочу сказати що наша позиція
щодо законопроекту 137 щодо ПДФО вона
очевидна кожна копійка має іти на
підтримку Збройних Сил України отак як
Київрада мільярд направила на а
підрозділи конкретні підрозділи
конкретні проекти по безпілотник там по
техніці так мають робити Всі сьогодні
місцеві ради очевидно що ніяких коштів
на бруківки на озера на павлінах там і
лебедів бути не може